hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be a little bit of gameplay from
arcanite I'm gonna put the rest on my
game channel I'll have links for
everything in the description so let's
have some fun check this out a little
barbecue what a nice way to start things
I'm gonna try not talk over the
cutscenes so there's a lot of talking
early on in this this really part is how
it happened this is supposed to be like
the last Arkham Knight games I don't
know if that's gonna be true or not
because it makes like a billion dollars
[Music]
my favorite thing about this is they
Kevin I want to go to a tree method I
press the button under an evil battery
best self and then we waited Gotham
braces itself for the inevitable power
struggle but it didn't come crime
actually fell
deep down I knew war was coming I was
just waiting for someone who pulled
[Music]
keep your eyes peeled for Easter eggs
when they're in really close-up scenes
like this I've already seen a couple
Black Canary ones there's a lot of
Superman Easter eggs in here too
Stan Lee is missing apparently Stan
Lee's I'm like unlike the missing poster
there I'm sure there's some banks so
what'll it be your usual sure okay
chicken salad with no dressing no you
know what make it waffles with a side of
bacon don't tell my wife whatever you
say officer the heart attack I'll get
him before the scarecrow does hey I'm
sorry to interrupt your dinner officer
Owens there's a guy smoking over there
in the corner booth what an [ __ ] yeah
wait here I'll have a word time to kick
some butt kickin butt and eatin waffles
excuse me sir there's no smoking in here
push it
that is what they call a jump-scare
karni give us the kiss kiss the zombie
he's like Resident Evil
and seen this demonstration used just
five ounces of my latest toxin from
tomorrow this will seem like child's
play Gotham this is your only warning
[Applause]
I think that's the guy from fringe and
from Sleepy Hollow he plays the one of
the Horsemen of the Apocalypse
war
[Music]
scarecrows threat war
yesterday there were six point three
million people in Gotham City
today Black Canary cause so many looks
like a strip club Jesus sheep she has a
really cool comic book that just they
rebooted it and she's like a rock singer
the only people on the street their
times were that enjoy the chaos
Gotham's penguin and two-faced scum
pound around town criminals and worse
not enough good people left to stop
Monterey Monterey Monterey Monterey
I know I know that's from Batman Begins
you know there's a big monorail thing
but honestly all I can think about is
the Simpsons monorail anytime someone
says monorail
it took just 24 hours for us to lose
control of the city tonight
Gotham's relying on one man to save us
all only one agency
[Music]
they're talking about Jimmy Olsen
if anybody's been reading the new Batman
Title Jim Gordon is like wearing a giant
mech suit
he's like the new Batman that mecha
Batman
[Music]
I'm thinking the character design on
this Batman this iteration but whenever
he talks it looks just like it looks a
little bit weird but usually you're not
looking at them in third perspective
let's fly around a little bit this whole
like the whole first part of the game is
just like figuring out the control
scheme I mean it's very similar to the
other Arkham games it's too bad you just
can't like grapple people that'd be
great weapon if you like scorpion from
Mortal Kombat you come here just beat
the [ __ ] out of some guys for a second
so you can tune the difficulty like way
up it just gives them more help and
makes them move a little bit quicker the
game is like automatically set on normal
so I mean you shouldn't have any
problems in this stage this is mostly
meant to be most this is mostly meant to
be fun
I like how like big games now or like 10
games jammed into one game they've like
a little bit of MORTAL KOMBAT a little
bit of Grand Theft Auto you can actually
you can do this like all over the city
it's I mean it's it's like a free roam
style mission but the games like the
storyline won't advance until you go to
your next checkpoint this is actually
the first time I play I'm plate Lee's my
first game on ps4 it's had an Xbox
forever and usually I play PC games but
the share features on ps4 are way better
and it's way better than Xbox one right
now I'm just glad you made it out okay
sorry I've got to go
stay safe Barbara you still know how to
make an entrance
how's the evacuation going last bus
crossed the city limits an hour ago I'm
just glad my little girl got out when
she did and now the real work begins
gtfo a lead on scarecrow we were
tracking an unknown military vehicle
speeding through Chinatown it's the only
lead we've had all night but they gave
us the slip with the evacuation I just
don't have the manpower left in the city
if you find it tell your men not to
engage I'll deal with it
do you really think scarecrows crazy
enough to detonate a chemical weapon in
Gotham I won't let them definitely in
case you need to reach me it's going to
be a long night
we've got a 1033 in Sector two missing
patrol car hey Batman
yeah and he's gone however a damn time
he actually sounds like the guy from
elementary Oracle I need a location of
unit 247 already working on it
how's my dad doing he's holding up
somehow he always does okay I'm sending
through this markers location be careful
it's too bad she's black and white you
can't see the gingers guts pork boardin
from from this like the voice actor
sounds like the district police chief
from elementary the sherlock TV show on
CBS actually gets a pretty good voice
talent it's like they basically they
spend almost 10 - let me mount ten times
but they spend just about as much money
on a big game like this as they do on
like one hundred and fifty million
dollar movie
movies are like a billion dollar
industry video games are like a ten
billion dollar industry that's why like
people always wonder if video games are
gonna turn into movies and they they
already did like they did a long time
ago new games are way more powerful form
of storytelling and it's a party now
take that you like take that bathroom
use gimme gimme gimme
man I always like making fight sound
effects whenever I'm in the middle of a
fight
you're safe thanks Batman
I thought somebody wants to play the
city's overrun we don't stand a chance
stay here I'll send someone to pick you
up what are you doing
evening the odds tenten tenten tenten
this is where like you know like the
Batman music you in this is probably one
of my favorite sequences from early in
the game
so this is where the game turns into
Grand Theft Auto Oracle I need to track
that military vehicle score cards picked
up the pursuit I'm relaying its location
now
Daniel do this
it took me forever to get the car work
late with the controls in the car like
it does not turn fast actually it's not
that all this the entire environment you
can destroy everything sitting so you
can just even drive it through like a
tank just like anything you can eat yes
care of the vehicle I need to
interrogate the driver and find out what
he knows
[Music]
you come here now where's scarecrow
go to hell honestly like I don't know
why like a normal level criminal
whatever say that's a Batman talk or
I'll crush every bone in your body okay
if you lie I'll break the other one I
mean that's the whole thing about Batman
he's just as bad as the criminals only
he's on site of justice so it's not like
scarecrow would do something worse to
you if you gave them up to Batman Oracle
check the chemical analysis I've just
uploaded sure
scarecrows new toxin an uncontaminated
sample computer what are you going to do
scarecrows got a safe house nearby I'm
going to pay him a visit let's hope this
is the break we've been waiting for so
thank you for watching everybody what
I'm gonna do is the rest of this
gameplay is gonna go on my bonus Channel
Charlie streams there's a link for that
in the description below but mostly you
guys have probably heard about it before
or a lot of you might not have I'll
upload a new video every day I'll try to
stream this weekend too so just stay
tuned on Facebook and Twitter for
updates on what's going on with that
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow